vraiment les contes et les chansons sont totalement en
deçà de votre énormité o Smaug le
prodigieux
nous sommes les nains d'Erebor nous sommes
venus récupérer notre patrie je vous offre
mon aide comment savons-nous qu'il
ne nous trahira pas il n'y a pas  Roi sous la
montagne et il n'y en aura jamais ça
ne s'arrêtera pas ici à chaque victoire ce
mal grandira Legolas est devenu très
friand il ne lui donnera pas d'espoir
là où il n'y en a pas
n'a pas le droit d'entrer dans cette montagne
des seuls arrivés  nous avons été aveugles dans notre
aveuglement Je me souviens que tu t'es retourné
J'ai trouvé quelque chose dans les tunnels gobelins
veux-tu financer mon courage Kurt tu en auras
besoin
Dragon Fire et ruine c'est ce que tu
nous apporteras il ne peut pas voir au-delà de
son propre désir
Je ne risquerai pas cette quête pour la vie
d'un cambrioleur son nom est Bilbo viens
maintenant ne sois pas timide dans la lumière